we are witnessing a new global epidemic
we're now more than ever
people are feeling disenfranchised in
their lives they're feeling a lack of
contentment feeling that they're not
living their true life purpose and in
this video I'm going to share with you
on how to identify what your life
purpose is but first let's discuss the
obvious the world is getting crazier
people are working themselves to the
bone and they're asking themselves well
is light is there more to life than just
working five days a week for the weekend
and of course for the paycheck I mean
we're seeing how the surveys are done
where it's not just Millennials by the
way where job dissatisfaction and
disengagement is soaring where you have
nearly three out of four people
essentially that just don't like what
they do for a living or if you look at
the fact that depression rates have
skyrocketed over the last decade but
nowhere is it more apparent when you
look at the fact that people are dying
with regrets they're not living their
lives and like I said this is a true
epidemic there have been surveys
conducted at various hospitals and
hospice cares where people are asked who
are on their deathbed they know that
they're on their way out and they're
asked if they could go back in their
lives and do something different what do
they wish they could do different and
what's amazing is that there were five
answers that were so common let me just
show you answer number one which was the
most common which is I wish I had the
courage to live a life true to myself
not the life others expected of me I'm
gonna discuss that because that's
incredibly important but then to get
through the others the other four first
number two I wish I hadn't worked so
hard number three I wish I had the
courage to express my feelings for I
wish I had stayed in touch with my
friends and five I wish I had let myself
be happier now real quick
three maybe for these you could argue
our straight-up work or a career related
I mean come on I wish I had stayed in
touch with friends let's be honest you
don't see your friends as much because
you work so much right number five I
wish should I let myself be happier well
okay
so you spent most of your life working
for a job that you didn't love right
there you go so let me get back to
number one real quick I wish I had the
courage to live a life true to myself
and not the life others expected to me I
mean how many people choose a career
because of their parents push them into
it or maybe they went to school thinking
that was the way to go or society as a
whole we don't we don't think for
ourselves I mean I love this quote by
Ralph Waldo Emerson to be yourself in a
world that is constantly trying to make
you something else is the greatest
accomplishment and how true this is it's
always the people that are trying to fit
in and just coast through society and
check off the boxes right but where's
that getting us again people are dying
with regrets and people want now more
than ever are living this with this lack
of purpose in their life what we have to
start asking ourselves is who do we want
to be not what but who because we have
free will we have choices and today can
be the choice that you make to SOT to
decide that you know what I'm not happy
in my life there are other things that I
dream about doing and I just don't do
and why don't you do it well for a bunch
of reasons you can't because of you
can't sacrifice the pay or you're just
not in a position to be able to do it
right now when you put things off and it
never gets done and before you know what
you're one of these people on their
death beds dying with their own regrets
you have to realize that any dream that
you have that you want is absolutely
possible and it's you that's creating
the obstacles because of your
preconceived notions and life experience
you think that you know what because
something's not in front of you that's
so obvious it's not apparent on how to
do it that you assume that it's not
possible when it is you have to get
creative but ultimately it's our fears
that get the best of us and prevent us
from doing this there's a quote by Les
Brown which is too many of us are not
living our dreams because we are living
our fears I mean think about this it's
self-doubt that we gets in our mind that
we can't do this because we're either
worried what others will think or were
worried about failure
self-doubt kills more dreams than any
failure ever will in fact then you get
into another quote real quick by Les
Brown which is the wealthiest place on
the planet is the graveyard because in
the graveyard we find inventions that we
were never exposed to ideas dreams never
became a reality
hopes and aspirations that were never
acted upon think about that how many
people including yourself wish that they
could do something different and we just
don't do it imagine how much this world
has been robbed of
whether it's the cure for cancer or
whatever it is because people decided to
take the easy path
they had self-doubt they had fear in
fact this reminds me of a quote by
Aristotle I share in a second which is
that a lot of people are afraid of
criticism they're afraid what other
people are gonna think if they decide to
just go their own way because it's not
Frank get the answer the number one
answer to people's greatest regret which
is that they wish that they had lived a
life for themselves and not what other
people have wanted out of them they
didn't think for themselves that they
were too afraid of not fitting in well
like Aristotle said there is only one
way to avoid criticism do nothing say
nothing and be nothing in a big part of
what it comes down to is having self
trust to trust your instincts to trust
your intuition you have to listen to
yourself and know what it is that you
want because otherwise how's the world
gonna treat you we're seeing this again
it's an epidemic and now is the time for
people to start making real changes in
their life today is the day that you
decide you know what I'm not completely
content in my life
there are things that I really want to
do I have dreams and I'm not going to be
that guy on my deathbed or that girl or
whoever that has these regrets so this
is the part where people are wondering
well wait a second what does this mean
though how do I turn this into making
money and surviving because it's so easy
to say when you're not the one that has
bills and how am I going to support my
family and do all this it's too late for
me to make these changes
no it's not it's never too late the
obstacles are blinding you that you're
not seeing the other possibilities that
can get you there it's the same thing
that's worked out in my life I went back
to school because I thought I wanted to
be mr. corporate America and make a
bunch of money sitting behind a desk
until I realized that was gonna bring me
nothing but suffering and it was I was
living a miserable life and I couldn't
figure out why and the reason is is that
I I felt like I didn't make any
decisions in my life to where I was that
were thought of on my own I listen to
what other people thought I should do
and I didn't think for myself but like I
said earlier in the video how do you
find your life purpose well there's a
series of questions for questions in
fact look at this Venn diagram what do
you love doing what are you good at what
does the world need and what can you be
paid for those four questions are what
you have to explore on your own just as
I did
this is worked incredibly effective for
me although it didn't work in one day
either but you have to look at various
things like what is it that you truly
love what are you passionate about ask
yourself the times of your life that you
were most proud of yourself
what was that what were you doing or
also that times in your life that you
were the most happy what did that look
like what was your life at that time
what were you doing you just have to get
creative and think outside the box on
how you can make that your own in fact
that reminds me of another quote and
this is by Joseph Campbell for sure
which is you are the hero of your own
story you need to map out your life as
if you're watching a movie that you
would love an entertaining movie
whatever that may be
your storyline and you have free will
it cannot be overstated and how
significant that is that most people
don't realize that you always have a
choice you are empowered with reason you
are empowered with knowledge and
intellectual capabilities as being a
human being right you always have a
choice and even when you think that the
choices are limited you always have a
choice so now is the time for people to
start waking up and realizing and taking
control of their own lives live their
life like it's the story or movie that
you would watch right it can be full of
adventure gonna be full of whatever it
is but you can become that I'm on the
path to doing and I'm gonna prove it so
if I can do it and I have so many things
to share about myself so I look forward
to developing this channel and sharing
more about me and my journey and how I
came to this and so look forward to all
that but you can do it if I can do it so
can you because the last thing you want
to do is become the these people that
are dying on their death beds so again
there are four questions you have to ask
yourself what do you love doing spend
time pondering this you won't figure out
in one day because there are so many
things that you probably love right what
are you good at well I'm sure you
realize things that you're not good at
and you probably know I'm good at a
bunch of things but you have to combine
that and again it goes back to the Venn
diagram combine all four of these
questions what does the world need and
how can I make money doing it when you
can bind these four things and this
actually is something that I use it took
me oh man many weeks of pondering over
months and months to be able to figure
so it's something you might not be over
to figure out in one day but the bottom
line is this the world's getting crazy
we all have choices in the world is what
we make of it and your life is your own
story it's your own journey and don't
become part of this demographic of
people that are falling into the
depression that are falling into
disengagement at work because I know
that many people watching this are but
you have a choice and today is the day
that you decide you know what I'm gonna
identify what my life purpose is I'm
gonna learn what my life purpose is and
I'm going to live it I'll leave it at
that guys I'm Jimmy this is bright
insight I look forward to reading
comments on this and I hope this brings
fulfillment to somebody this video might
not be for everyone but I'm sure that if
it's not for you it's certainly for
somebody that you know in your own life
but I'll leave it at that
I have many videos to come and a whole
wide variety of topics take care
everybody